ci vuole fare c'è scritto di scappare
dalla nonna ma dove benvenuti sono stati
9 stiva e skype rombo dovremmo scappare
dalla nonna non avete detto che tu per
tu per divertente dai finalmente ha
cambiato cappello e finalmente vitale
ammesso scarpe mi piace qui sotto se
questo video raggiunge i 10 mila mi
piace palermo anche scappa dal nonno
evitare se pare che per gli arancioni le
treccine davvero no e non mi seguite
entra su internet ma mezz'ora e prenditi
poco iniziato ecco qua la nonna già ci
sta guardando
qualcuno suonerà come stiamo dietro alla
casa della nonna si è scritto non è
impazzita e dobbiamo scappare di andare
velocemente nell'altra stanza per la
regia è diventato tutto rosso non lo so
però bisogna saltare su questo il legale
che belli ma questo rumore
c'è qualcosa di strano denti finti e
bolle scritto livello due denti finchè
bolle beh forse dentiere ecco bravo ha
detto bisogna stare attento anche alle
botte mandandoli somatico da dentro
l'armadio sassi ma c'è grande da casa
dell'anno sono altro mondo qui
nell'armadio narnia qua sopra
forse li qua che cosa questo verme che
cos'è saprei aiuta paura labirinto dove
dobbiamo andare sulle strategie chiuso è
chiuso allora proviamo speriamo di non
morire crescita ogni livello a loro tre
porta chiusa scritto sembra che la nonna
abbia messo delle trappole per non farsi
scappare forse c'è qualcosa che può
rompere il legno per poter scappare
vediamo qualcosa che pur rom per il
legno
faccio un pulsante premio è aperta ai ci
sta guardando secondo me e rabbia no
questo è difficile
[Musica]
no che andiamo per 60
valga solo per un momento ma ho visto
che queste skyroom c'erano 5 6 4
giocatori collegati solo in questo
momento non si tifa 130 mila mi piace è
una delle skip rombo più popolari piace
tantissimo si sono riuscito a passare
come fatto di pc e si hanno preso quella
moneta però adesso ci riprovo no proprio
no le mani a 20 io l'ho presa aiuto è
troppo difficile perché le foto la rete
di verticale passati ed equa in questa
porta si unico mitoli sono tutte le cose
della nonna che bello tutti i giganti o
no nella fase 5 c'è scritto trucchi
mortali guarda ce l'ho fatta
ma che cos'è ma perché la nonna tutte
queste stellari dart mani fate fare
motoseghe sembra che la donna abbia
dimenticato di coprire questo bottone
per disattivare le trappole brava passa
lo abbiamo fatta noi c'è stato mobile
inferno scritto o no la nonna sta
bruciando tutte le sue cose
questa giornata sta diventando ancora
più pazza perché la bruciando tutti i
sistemi mobili perché proprio pazzo
quest'anno
abbiamo fatto allora c'è scritto gargani
della nonna grandi risultati studi
scatolette teca senza farsi freddo però
anche le crocchette o fu che corrono
che carino questo è un gatto nero con la
cravatta e quasi a gaza grinza con la
cravatta rosa
no no mi sono stragelato sono fatte più
attenta e non saltare sopra che c'è un
altro gatto cosa fa la nonna a colazione
guarda se la nonna li sta cucinando vedi
attenti a non cadere dentro nelle
padelle
dove dobbiamo saltare sicuramente col
manico dalla padella è sicuramente non
desta no ok mia cugina antonella oppure
andare ma vediamo sulla carota e sul
luogo per prendere la moneta e poi di
nuovo sul manico mi stava facendo aiuto
ucciderà adesso dobbiamo evitare il
mattarello non è cattiva ci vuole ci
vuole spiaccicare facilissimo evitare al
mattarello e vi amiamo lavare le cose
attento a non cadere dentro a lavando le
stoviglie quindi dobbiamo cercare di non
cadere dentro all'acqua ok ma come ho
fatto
che carini la papera ma scusa ma la
nonna lava i piatti con le passerelle un
po confusa lisa ecco vitale leader o
biscotti che i biscotti si girano e ti
fanno cadere un biscotto gigante va bene
purché pro non mi fanno venire il sacco
di balle scritto c'è un portale dentro
il biscotto forza dentro il biscotto sì
partiamo dal portale si deve a salvare
prima di proseguire
sì è vero tinta dobbiamo evitare la tv
che fare con la vernice è attento voi
dovete bellissimo che schifo ruby per
divertenti molto bella anche se ancora
non ho capito cos'è questa cosa per me
da che parte dice vediamo se riusciamo a
farlo con chi allora perché l'avete
detto voi cioè se spari secondo me papà
spariscono più noto è quello al centro
ed è quello alzato quella destra e ora
la notte quindi qual è questa sinistra
si disputava sopra
[Musica]
sì perché la nonna è così grande forse
dobbiamo provare a correre attorno a lei
quando si stanca però che non dobbiamo
entrare anche nella sua bocca io irischi
proprio mentre nella bocca di qualcuno
dobbiamo saltare su questi gomitoli di
lana che belli tutti colorati la toro ha
detto che l'ultimo è difficile per me
divertente queste scritte
ecco la nota i cult secondo me si vuole
mangiare ne sono sicura questo è
difficilissimo andare sul filo blu e
allo stesso tempo saltare sugli altri è
strano che non sono portale internet a
dirlo è guardato il disastro che ci
stiamo qua ci siamo quasi
adesso dobbiamo salire a qui sulla donna
attenta ai biscotti bisogna salire sui
biscotti si attenta che si muovono
non ho visto solo lui
fate dire l'ultimo posto in cui vorrei
vediamo scopriamo che conta mangiato una
mangiata biscotti interi senza grafica
di una carota giriamo marino per non
farla e ci sono delle piante nella bocca
della nonna non si fa visse quei poveri
biscotti dice farsi 19 perché ci sono
dei piatti o no no sono sfracellato è
iscritto di scegliere la porta giusta
mi sa che quasi dividiamo io vedo da una
parte e tu vai dall'altra c'è scritto
attraversa la porta a destra la destra
quindi questa parte era uno scherzo
riuscì fu certo mi fiderò più di vitale
io vado tra un astuto forse bisogna
cambiare porta in ogni passaggio tipo
qua bisogna cambiare perché non è mia
moglie
salviamo mista che questa è proprio
quella umbra
è molto difficile ma bisogna saltare non
appena arriva la cosa schifosa
vabbè questo evento con le frecce ce la
fai è facile senza saltare ci sono
uscito io sono come frusta cammino in
area cis posti con le frecce piano piano
se vuoi prenderlo in avanti brava brava
ha visto stato molto più semplice così
ma c'è scritto di scappare dalla nonna
ma dove vengono solo usciamo di qui la
stessa ho saltato questo nome ho preso
preso dopo pubblice la nonna con lo
scudo che ti vuole schiacciare o no ma
mi ha schiacciato come ho fatto
ma bisogna fatta non ho capito
devi saltare a scappare dalla nonna
questa scusa era in mezzo alla strada
qui aiuto ma oggi devo anche la marchi
si è vero qui per ora se ti fermi muri
praticamente devi fare tutto di fretta
eccola io non lascio passare no non ti
puoi fermare devi sempre correre
vabbè troppo difficile si sta sempre più
tardi recupero ha aiutato mi ha preso la
nonna mia spiaccicato con lo scooter dai
portese la forza
cos'è questo rumore la nonna che mi
rincorre aiuto ho paura a girardi che
dovranno però fare rete sono andato a
volte anch'io
[Musica]
hai mai un ufficio ma anche le macchine
posso fare io non lo so sto ancora tutta
la macchina giochi ma mi ha passato ma
la nonna dove la scoparsa ok né appena
spiaccicato col suo scooter nero caputo
cordiali d'offerta credo che l'abbiamo
sconfitta non ci credo ce l'abbiamo
fatta
raccontiamo queste ultime monete antiche
su questo bisogna scegliere un colore
scelto il viola uscendo il verde abbiamo
preso tutti questi pezzi vivo solo
abbiamo fatto è stato super divertire
from della nonna si parte da un bel viso
anch'io la parte finale mi è piaciuta
troppo questa la donna sta vigilando
scooterone mai visto mentre il capo da
ma da farà troppo divertente
lasciate un vi piace potete vedere anche
le scritte room del nonno era vi
lasciamo 4 casellina cliccare per vedere
i nostri altri mi raccomando cliccate su
quella che preferite
nella missione ciao